hello everyone today I will talk about
cd8 positive cytotoxic T cell now in one
word cd8 positive cytotoxic T cell are
reserve army branch of the immune system
so they are ready for combat for final
infections let's just take a look at
from where the cd8 positive T cells
develop so just like normal T cell or
b-cell the development starts from the
bone marrow and everything starts from
hematopoietic pluripotent stem cell or
HSCs from hematopoietic pluripotent stem
cell they develop into the void
progenitor cells the lymphoid progenitor
cells give rise to precursor T cells now
precursor T cell then entered the
bloodstream and migrate towards the
thymus gland inside the thymus there are
sequential stages of development of a
t-cell in a particular stage known as
double positive stage the T cells the
mature T cells expresses both cd8 and
cd4 co-receptors now depending upon
whether they're recognizing MHC one bind
peptide or MHC two bound peptide the
different shape into either helper T
cell or into cytotoxic T cell now if
they can recognize MHC one bound
peptides then they would down regulate
cd4 expression and upregulate CVA
expression ultimately it would switch
its fate towards cytotoxic T cell
whereas if it recognize peptides bound
in MHC class 2 molecules it would
upregulates its cd4 expression and down
regulate cd8 expression ultimately it
would become our helper T cell now once
the cytotoxic T cell is formed it is
still naive it doesn't recognize
yet in order to be mature it need to
recognize it need to learn how to
recognize antigen from dendritic cells
and also another trigger of aisle
interleukin 2 helps these cytotoxic T
cell to proliferate and expand clonally
and give rise to a lot of cytotoxic T
cell now cytotoxic T cell provides
immunity against viruses so let's just
take a look how scientists of cig T cell
fights against the viruses now here are
some epithelial cells which are infected
by these viruses once the virus entered
this cell the virus injected in this
genome and the genome is successfully
replicated transcribed and translated
and ultimately viral proteins are formed
the cells inside the cells there are
always degradation machinery for
proteins known as Proteus ohms some of
the viral proteins are also degraded by
these Proteus ohms here are some viral
proteins which are degraded by the
proteasome they enter the endoplasmic
reticulum via tab transporter and load
it on to class one MHC molecule
eventually the class 1 MHC molecule
would be displayed on the surface of the
cell containing the viral antigen now
cd8 positive T cells are always looking
for wine of peptides displaced on class
1 MHC molecules now serial positive T
cells would secrete transients and
perforin
and ultimately lead to the apoptosis of
the virus infected cell and that's how
it would save this nearby cells from
further infection let's just take a look
at how a CD 8 positive T cell kills its
target
so cd8 positive T cells or cytotoxic T
cells use two different strategies to
kill its target cell one it secretes
perforin and granzymes which gaped
endocytosed by the target cell and are
furring leaked out from the endocytosis
vesicle and perforin can interact with
mitochondrion pro apoptotic proteins
known as beat or backs
now these perforins and peed make the
mitochondrial membrane porous such that
cytochrome c could be released and
cytochrome c is not expected in the
cytosol once present in the cytosol
cytochrome c can interact with a puff
one now a puff one is one of the bad
players a puff one Cleaves inactive
format of caspase-3 and makes it active
so here is an inactive pro gas phase 3
which is cleaved with the help of a puff
one and cytochrome C complex two cleaved
an active gas phase 3
now caspase-3 is an executor gasp it's
caspase-3 can do a lot of things they
have protease activity they can further
activate several other protease they
cleave the microtubule they chop the DNA
and ultimately the form they need to
program cell death or apoptosis there is
another way by will cytotoxic T cell can
induce apoptosis of its target cell
now cytotoxic T cell expresses first
began where as Fuss receptors are
actually expressed on the normal cells
now first first ligand interaction
ultimately leads to activation of pro
caspase-8 through an active form of
cleaved
caspase-8 now cleaved or active
caspase-8 can also lead to further
cleavage of inactive caspase-3 to active
caspase-3 which would ultimately lead to
apoptosis by these two parallel
mechanism a cytotoxic T cell can kill
its target
and thereby cytotoxic t-cell can save
other cell from further damage or
further infection and that concludes my
video on this topic if you liked my
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you